who what do you got on this new album um
I really didn't do features man I I have
first class with Larry June I have uh
first class with Larry June I have swear
I'm with Tia and my nephew Nico but
other than that it's just strictly me
man I hate to do this cuz my daughter
calling do you think man hey truth I'm
doing an interview right now what's
wrong
baby okay soon as I get done I'mma come
get you
okay you hear me yeah all right love
you I know you is that your daughter
that lives out here yeah yeah yeah she
just moved to um she in she in Vegas now
but yeah she saving tax
money she here actually she here now I
just flew at here cuz you know I say you
don't have to worry about that in Texas
though yeah yeah St you know she a Texas
baby she
um TI you said t yeah my nephew Nico
other than that it's strictly me um I
wanted this tape this tape is just kind
of like the the reintro to me cuz you
got to realize for years I ain't really
been able to just put out consistent
music or album because you may have
somebody getting killed by police or you
may have a natural disaster and you know
when it come to that I'm focused on the
people you know what I'm saying so I
wasn't able so this is the first one to
kind of get me back in the okay he's
still on it you know what I'm saying
because now when I'm moving around I got
so many relationships people overly
excited you know what I'm saying like
and also a lot of people are are there's
a whole new wave of people who associate
who don't really associate you with
being a rapper right right that's they
look at you as a businessman they look
at you as somebody who gives back who's
helping people during the hurricane
somebody who's you know just tied in in
so many different ways culturally that
it's like hey also I do this at a high
level right so now um this album I
wanted it to be just more of me just a
good vibe nothing crazy just straight
good vibe music that people can relate
to from all walks of life all Jas you
know all A's brackets and after that
then I'm I'm going come in and start
putting pressure on them um I want to
know how uh cuz right now two of the
most hottest rappers period are from
your region dbab and that Mexican OT
yeah yeah both of them doing their thing
both of them are doing their thing I was
about to say how much are you kind of
paying attention to like what they're
doing cuz uh man OT just sold out a show
in La he just finished his first
headline of tour and yeah yeah you know
these guys are doing things I'm
definitely familiar with them man you
know I I always Embrace people early
before the stuff start really jumping up
so it was always love man you know I'm
one of the people man I salute
congratulate you you know just really I
stand behind just our city anyway
especially you know I love
watching some of the younger generation
go to do their thing you know what I'm
saying to have their shot cuz everybody
had their shot it's no point of watching
certain people hog it like Blossom for
the neck so it's them you know um I'm
going to be introducing the world to the
rejects which is a bunch of Street cats
from the city that have their own fan
basee that make authentic music that I
feel need to be showed to the world and
displayed so the rejects coming and you
of course you know that's me you have
big Tony Cal
Wayne ski taste Jack boy 30
ways um l
savage Millie
bcks uh fast
money um trying not to forget get
anybody I be my mind be so so all over
man but uh definitely got to check for
all them that tape going to be something
cuz
I'm sound that sounds like a massive
like that sounds like more like a
collective like the wuang clan kind of
you yeah yeah it's definitely it's
definitely interesting man they first
single going to come out called
detention and it may release real soon
you know what I'm saying they got the
visual shot for that um I mean we just
Jack boy yeah we just we working man
everybody doing their thing yeah I think
it's refreshing too because I do feel
like no matter like you know we always
think of like the puke H the peak uh
htown kind of like you know 05
0304 you know Mike Jones Paul walls uh
swisser house um Slim Thug yourself yeah
what I like about the new [__] I'm
hearing is it sounds very Texas and
obviously Travis has put out a lot of
records at sound very Texas and paid a
lot of homage to to H toown but I feel
like it's it's just dope to kind of see
like these dudes making like
Unapologetic Texas Music and it work on
like a big level too so the reason it
works right Texas support is Texas
support you never even really got to
leave Texas make right CU it's so it's
right if anyone's ever driven through
Texas it's crazy yeah definitely it
never ends yeah so you got you got that
and um
um when you have that and a foundation
built around it it trickers in the other
market and you know they they try to
feel like oh what's that what's what's
what's that child jam and then they get
on it then they go put their people on
it so it works man there's nothing wrong
with staying true to your roots you know
so a lot of times people try and do
other stuff to get in or fit in and it's
like if you have just held up a little
longer your time would have came cuz
people going to get to your way
everybody everybody have their wave it's
it's it never fails think about it every
Market have their time I look at a guy
like uh you know even like um you know
shout outs to like a guy like peso peso
and and and and those guys like s Waka
it feel like his wave is like finally
kind of connecting on like a really big
level and he's been kind of in
independently like yeah yeah hand in
business for so long and it feels like
he like he had the BET thing last year
like and it's like oh like finally
there's like a national Spotlight on
what he's been doing for so long so I
feel like Texas htown in general even
Dallas is going crazy a big X to plug is
incredible yeah yeah um so it's just
dope to see Texas have like another just
New Wave It's naturally man from Houston
the Dallas they is just naturally
Hustlers you know um we definitely had a
Hustlers mentality we come from where we
used to slanging stuff out the Trump
yeah on the regular you know and and
also with the hustle mentality is we not
necessarily taking No for answer we
going to find a way to get in and fit in
however we can and when I say we I'm
speaking just for the Texas culture in
general for sure so yeah um when you
stay consistent and you do things like
that it's definitely going to hit people
Radars and then when they hit their
Radars you know you take it and you you
you magnify it and grow it and blow it
up I always wondered you've done so much
for your city I feel like when people
think of your city you're synonymous
with it at this point you're a community
leader at this point did you ever get
unbanned from the Box in Houston so it's
crazy you say in Houston bro I've been
banned I was never just banned in
Houston it was radio one yeah worldwide
still that way so Radio One the company
there's still the trade the truth ban
yeah mhm wow well bro was there ever any
has there been any sort I mean look that
was like what over 10 years ago right
like that was so long ago it might have
been longer than 14 years yeah it's been
so long like you would think people grow
people I I definitely grow I mean I I
haven't thought about them I don't I
don't I don't speak on them I don't I
just keep it moving you know I found my
lane and it works yeah you know you're
also not an artist that necessarily
needs radio to be successful like right
you know and that's another reason when
I take time to salute a lot of the the
the Young Artists coming up they created
ways where radio isn't necessarily even
need it anymore for you to to chart or
for you to tour for you to monetize
support your family right right so I've
definitely it's a blessing I've I've
seen a lot of people come and go and I'm
still here and then when you think when
I actually did have radio I wouldn't
knowwhere near as big as I am now that's
some real [__] that's some real [__]
yeah that's true